hey guys it is Friday again which means
I'm here to catch you up on the five
biggest things that happen in gaming
history
this week ei finally gave us a glimpse
of what we'll be getting in the $60 DLC
pasta Star Wars Battlefront
while the publisher is still being
pretty vague about exactly what will be
included in the DLC pub Co peace and
will revealed some more information
during a recent earnings call he
explained what we've announced is four
extra packs over the next 12 to 18
months coming since launch you'll see
new universes that you're gonna see you
player actions obviously new weaponry as
well the DLC path will also give you
access to new content in two weeks
before everyone else
and to give you the exclusive shoot
faster note the fallout 4 app has
arrived on iOS and Android just in time
for your life to disappear down a
wasteland hole when fallout 4 arrives on
November 10 you can use the app as a
remote pip-boy device which connects
with your core game on news feed or
consoles you're able to do everything
your in-game clip boy can do only with
more convenience up spring controls this
means checking on your stats inventory
map and radio equipping weapons in armor
as well as playing holotape games right
now you can run the app in demo mode and
play the holotape game as comic command
this is the same app you'll want to get
going if you manage to get ahold of the
life-sized Pip Boy which fits your phone
inside
another pull-up for things here's the
lowdown on the game special editions and
pre-order bonuses if you haven't made up
your mind yet the ultra-rare pip-boy
edition I just mentioned is
unfortunately entirely out of stock the
120 dollar bundle included the wearable
Pip Boy as well as a special case poster
ends the game first Buy has the
exclusive Gold Edition which will run
you 85 bucks and offers up the game the
DLC pass and a pair of sweet vault boy
socks to keep your feet cozy during your
massive full marathon there's also the
$90 digital deluxe edition for Xbox one
which bundles the game and DLC pass as
well as the Xbox one bundle which
includes a one terabyte system and
copies before at four and three
pre-order bonuses include the perk
poster with all physical pre-orders a
mr. handy an Elsa pack for dota 2 if you
buy on Steam a free copy of fallout 3
playable via backward compatibility on
Xbox one and a full full garage static
theme the ps4
hols of warcraft subscriber numbers are
at an all-time low
and blizzards that they no longer intend
to publicize them as they always have
the subscriber numbers currently stands
at 5.5 million and Blizzard have
traditionally revealed the current
figure every three months during their
quarterly earnings report Blizzard have
now announced that they will no longer
be disclosing regular subscriber numbers
as they believe they are better metrics
suited to indicating success of World of
Warcraft the game has a new expansion
pack entitled legion in the works
backwards compatibility for the xbox one
is very nearly upon us and here's what
you'll want to know about it the feature
will arrive as part of the new Xbox one
experience dashboard update on November
12 you'll be able to find a tab which
shows all backwards-compatible Xbox 360
titles that you can download digitally
the backwards compatible games list
which is 100 plus titles long will be
revealed on November 9 should you want
to load up a game on a physical disk
you'll simply need to enter it into your
xbox one every time you want to play
Microsoft have said your xbox 360 saves
will carry forwarding if you save them
to the cloud and all DLC purchased for
last gen will also show up let me know
down in the comments which last gen
games you're keen to play again and
which version of what port you decided
to go for this week on site that Chris
gives you the lowdown on what's cool in
the new Call of Duty we check out
fallout 2 bets Easter eggs and Lucy goes
over the story of black ops that is
everything I have to you this week as
always let me know what mattered to you
at be sure to have a great weekend and I
will catch you
Monday